plus de la moitié des entreprises ont
enregistré une chute d'au moins 20% de
leurs revenus en raison d'un kobe 19
selon une enquête de statistique canada
parmi elles 26% ont enregistré une
baisse de revenu de 50% au plus le
secteur de l'hébergement et de la
restauration a été durement touchée avec
près de trois entreprises sur quatre qui
ont vu leurs revenus baisser d'au moins
20% les entreprises des arts spectacles
loisirs sont fortement touchés tout
comme le commerce de détail
la grande question qu'on se pose est ce
qu'il y aura une saison touristique cet
été deux invités pour en parler ce soir
f par et pdg de l'association des hôtels
du grand montréal et mathieu guillon
directeur général de tourisme charlevoix
à la malbaie bonsoir bonsoir monsieur
guillon d'abord le vdd barrage policier
qui a été annoncé aujourd'hui les 4 18 4
11 et 18 mai dans les régions pour
charlevoix c'est le 18 mai est ce que
c'est bien reçus chez vous c'est
certainement bien reçu c'est sûr qu'au
niveau de l'industrie touristique à très
court terme ça change pas nécessairement
grand chose dans la mesure où on n'a pas
fait partie des trois triples
d'entreprises qui avaient été annoncés
l'avez certainement ouverture ceci étant
dit c'est quand même un très bon signal
en vue d'une reprise éventuelle des
activités
mais est ce que c'est un signal qui vous
dit oui on peut préparer une saison
touristique nous en fait là on
fonctionne actuellement sur un plan de
relance donc on travaille déjà à une
éventuelle reprise des activités
donc ça nous envoie quand même un
certain signale que quiconque il
pourrait y avoir une saison estivale
bien qu'elle risque d'être et pour
écourter ou en second du moins dans un
contexte extrêmement différent avec les
mesures sincères qui vont s'imposer mais
ça nous envoie quand même le signal
clair qu'on peut espérer une éventuelle
reprise des activités dans un avenir
assez rapproché est à paris à montréal
de déconfinement se fera quand même un
peu plus tardivement montréal qui on
comprend que c'est un peu plus complexe
parce que beaucoup plus de cas la crise
est plus aiguë à quoi on s'attend comme
saison tourisme
c'est qu'à montréal qui est quand même
névralgique pour les hôtels de la grande
région de montréal
mais d'abord les hôtels ont été jugés
savait donc pour que la moitié montbard
ce qui explique que sont poursuivis au
cours des dernières semaines
parce que c'était un vrai vraiment pas
beaucoup de clients dans les et elle est
maintenant dans les livres des
réservations pour toutes à toutes les
pratiques avaient même pour les mois
d'été l'annulation des festivals et
d'événements contribue certainement à
cet état de fait on va souhaiter qu'à
une certaine reprise totalement ton des
marchés de proximité est les clients
très locaux qui auront envie de faire un
séjour à montréal a tous moi je dis
qu'on va traiter ce qu est ce qu on
prépare quelque chose dans les hôtels
est ce qu'on est capable de planifier
quelque chose comme je vous donnais elle
est opération jamais fait c'est les
mesures de pascal gautrand terre ont
déjà été livrés en place conformément
aux règles de la santé publique
donc nous sommes prêts à accueillir des
clients si la demande est là le tourisme
d'affaires également qui n'est plus là
présentement et qui affecte les hôtels
effectivement l'interdiction de
rassemblements complexité dans mes mains
la tâche pour du tourisme adt à faire
quelquefois le rayon d'affaires ou un
congrès attend qu'il directive ne font
pas pu avoir quelques pu imaginer qu'on
aura beaucoup de clients matin michel
vion les gîtes les libéraux breakfast
l'hébergement les hôtels chez vous je
présume que ya beaucoup d'inquiétudes
également ça c'est certain
comme le dit madame paris c'est sûr qu'à
très court terme quand il y aura une
reprise des activités
on risque de se concentrer beaucoup sur
le tourisme local en premier temps donc
évidemment c'est sûr que c'est souvent
les établissements d'hébergement qui
résidaient père dans cette étape le puis
éventuellement ça soit éventuellement
au niveau des marchés de proximité mais
il ya cette inquiétude le 1 est ce que
les gens vont être vraiment mesures vont
avoir la tête à voyager cet été puis la
deuxième chose c'est que les entreprises
aussi pour rassurer leur clientèle
devront mettre en place plusieurs
mesures sévères pour rassurer les
clients
donc il est évident si vous pourrez vous
preniez comme exemple un gîte que ça
peut nécessiter quand même des
investissements importants dans notre
rapport au chiffre d'affaires qu'ils ont
normalement le casino est fermé c'est
quand même un élément attractif
important à la malbaie oui c'est ça puis
l'industrie touristique la particularité
c'est que c'est une industrie où on a
besoin de plusieurs secteurs pour que ça
lève en même temps fait que c'est sûr
que si des attraits majeurs ne sont pas
et ouvert des raisons à cette terre
c'est sûr que l'industrie touristique
sera plus élevé ceci étant dit et en
région le concours beaucoup de plein air
de sentiers de randonnée
il est possible quand même que ce soit
plus ce genre de da trailer qui soit en
vogue cet été est ce que vous avez
entendu dire que le casino pourrait
rouvrir prochainement
on n'a pas eu d'écho à ce niveau là
vraiment nous en fait quand on n'a pas
de boule de cristal on suit vraiment les
prêtresses emmène donc tout le monde
donc on suit les mesures de santé
publique puis au fur et à mesure on va
adapter notre plan de relance en
conséquent des différentes annonces qui
seront faites par le gouvernement que la
santé publique f paré est ce que ça
prend un soutien précis ciblées pour le
tourisme et l'hôtellerie
certainement pour l'hôtellerie présent
là les entreprises n'ont plus aucun
revenu à toute fin pratique depuis
plusieurs mois on est habitué à gérer
toute attente et dernière étape n'a pas
dû perdre revenu au depuis prolongé
on sait pas combien de temps on va être
dans cette saison là les tchèques qu'on
doit ni contenu est important donc oui
on va demander une aide d'urgence aux
couleurs de la marque fondée d'exporter
ses couleurs j'espère que la natalité
soit de retour jeudi on est ce que vous
souhaite un plein dead ou plus
d'ouverture d'activité économique
je pense que ça tremblait de haut niveau
du plan d'ouverture d'activité
économique c'est sûr que nous on
respecte toujours la santé publique
donc j'aimerais qu'on va prioriser
d'ouvrir plus rapidement si c'est pas
quelque chose qui s'est curtat je pense
que la santé de la population est très
important au niveau 2 du plan daide je
pense que comme l'a dit madame paris
c'est vraiment essentiel
on a des bons échos de la part du
ministère du tourisme qui travaillent
très fort en vue d'un plan éventuel donc
on va suivre avec beaucoup d'attention
parce qu'étant une des industries sinon
la plus touchée mondialement par la
coved 19
c'est certain qu'il faudra un clin
d'oeil d'important pour être capable de
se relever de cette crise
est-ce que des hôtels qui passeront pas
au travers la crise madame paris mais
sur certaines fuites a perduré en
attendant un plan daide je crée pour la
survie de pudeur souhaitez-vous une
phase de la réouverture assez rapide
on voit que des classeurs serait donc le
plus rapidement possible mais en mettant
en demeure lucide quant à la lyrique
bon ben moi j'invite les gens de
montréal aller faire un tour dans
charlevoix j'invite les gens charlevoix
aller faire un tour dans la région de
montréal
quand ça sera le temps quand ça serait
le temps effectivement on fait les
choses dans l'ordre se dit on madame
parent et merci beaucoup et je vous
souhaite une bonne saison touristique
dans la mesure du possible
merci à vous en soirée